the democrat congress lady prila jaipal
is really honing in on the attack for
Donald Trump Assuming he's going to be
the nominee they're going to say this
guy is an insurrectionist he's a threat
to the country but they can't even say
it with a straight face well I
appreciate the passion from my friend
across the aisle and the outrage I think
we're all outraged about many things but
if we're going to talk about outrageous
things that have happened or things that
have never happened let's talk about the
fact that President Trump in cited an
erection an maybe that
too yeah you could talk about that too I
guess maybe we should talk about that
too the president incited an
Insurrection maybe we should talk about
the fact that the president the former
president was impeached twice maybe we
should talk about the fact that the
former president was convicted on 91
felony count she can't stop laughing
even as she's saying this